I would maybe I would maybe do.
Hold on a second.
Don't,
don't say a word.
Don't say a word.
Don't say a word until
this bitch gets cracking.
Bert Kreischer.
I want you to keep it together.
I want you to hold on.
I'm holding,
wants you to realize this is a
gun damn commercial free podcast.
Exceptional addition is an
except the podcast was so good.
It cannot be stopped or the greater good
of Shiva or Odin or Thor or Cassiopeia.
Did anybody ever wash up?
Cassiopeia is at the watch.
Some chick with some dude probably
wanted to fuck and he got all exaggerated
when she was named bear of fucking
constellation or some shit,
right?
Cassiopeia I bet her website's available.
That's good.
Is your pussy you have to be before
they named it constellation after it.
Not even like a tree.
Why on a rock,
not a mountain.
No.
A series of nuclear explosions
and the middle of the universe.
Why haven't they rebooted Thor and like
he got a haircut yet because [inaudible]
he's dope.
Don't be,
hey,
listen,
Brian,
you have a full head of hair.
You shouldn't be hating because I have
almost zero hair and I'm not hating.
Okay?
It's a matter of time
before I shaved my head.
It's your issues.
He should do it.
I just want to to the hair green things.
Oh yeah,
dude.
Shaving your head is a beautiful feeling.
Is it?
Do it.
Just do it.
Trust me.
Just do it once.
You obviously don't give
a fuck about your body.
Let's be realistic.
You've,
he's been working out a lot.
You're not gay.
You're you.
Let's be honest.
You know,
I love you,
but let's be honest.
If you were entering into
a bodybuilding contest,
I would say this guy does not want to win.
He is not trying to win sexiest.
Man.
I don't even look good in European speedo.
Oh,
not that there's anything wrong with that,
but let's be honest about our paths.
It's life,
ladies and gentlemen.
So death,
a death squad,
Scotland and desk got Ohio are losing
their fucking minds because they're told
you to stop communicating
with those people.
You don't know them.
You have not vetted them,
sir.
Brian does know,
goddammit.
None of them mother fuckers
have a proper filter in place.
We need to fucking set ups a
scientific checks and balances.
Much like the CIA uses.
Can't just decide.
You're going to let some mother
fucker send you some whiskey.
Oh,
I can't put coconut.
We have a refrigerator here
at a higher primates studios.
We're so not fucking around,
ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.
We were taking this to the next level.
Bert Kreischer.
Do you see what we're doing here?
My own Buddha.
His fucking care package from on it.
Yeah.
You got a care package from on it.
Then we got the boot are
responsible for my tattoo.
What was that?
The Buddha taught like,
hi guys are here.
You're done.
But Tattoos.
Are you going to,
are you going to,
I'm going to fill in my right arm.
Can we see your right?
That is the same.
Hmm.
The guy who did my arm,
first of all,
he's a beautiful artist and he's a cool
mother fucker name is Aaron Dellavedova
and he uh,
works at Guru Tattoo in San Diego.
I get,
I would get tattoo just to
hang out with that dude.
It's so cool.
I wonder if that,
I want to heal.
He's a real artist.
He usually eats really cool paintings.
I love his,
like his point of view.
Like it's so uniquely his own that
you remember that guy that was uh,
uh,
Jesse James Rather who's
married to Sandra Bullock.
Remember he had that affair with some
girl at Swat to Roscoe touch with him
before I saw no,
no,
no.
She didn't have that.
Yes,
yes.
No,
no,
no.
She was not a swipe power.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
she did.
How she did you?
She did not.
No,
no,
no.
She had swastikas tattooed.
So stop it.
Stop.
No,
swear to God.
She's really good at telling you.
I'll be showing you.
I'm telling you you're wrong.
What's her name is Michelle
dynamite or something like that.
But anyway,
my point is that she had this sleeve
and I looked at the sleeve and I said,
that's an Aaron Dellavedova Tattoo.
I could tell that his style
is so distinctive and I'm uh,
I'm,
I'm such a huge fan of
individual points of expression.
Why?
Or like,
um,
like there's certain like pool cues where
you could look at the pool cue and you
know,
that is a sugar tree.
That's a cue that Eric,
Chris May,
that is a cognizant that's acute,
that Joe Gold Mate,
but they have like this
individual point of expression.
Michelle,
my gate.
Yeah.
She did a Nazi.
That's what it was.
She want to have it attached.
Yeah.
She doesn't have tattoos like some
crazy photo shoot that she had to do.
Although it does say WP on her leg.
Yeah.
Like as in white power?
No.
Or how would it means yes or whoa.
Is that really what it means?
WP?
I'll think.
What else?
Oh,
uh,
with the coupe.
What was my point about her?
Uh,
you were talking about,
uh,
you're a tattoo artist.
Had her arm or something.
I saw her arm and one for arms.
I think it's a right sleeve.
Yeah.
His style is so distinct.
Did you start check out?
Well,
I looked on in California and I
was looking at all these different,
you know,
it's like you,
if you,
there's a lot of really
good artists in California,
especially you mean Kat von D
who we've had on the podcast.
Oh,
was a great podcast.
Yeah,
she was really cool.
There's this,
uh,
there's just,
there's so many,
like,
I don't even want to name names,
this is a million talented artists,
but when I saw Aaron's work on mine,
especially sleeves and big back pieces,
like his style is really
about big bold like pieces.
And when I started talking to him
like immediately we hit it off,
I was like,
this girl is cool as fuck.
He's so cool.
Like right away.
Like I was like,
like you know what,
you talk to someone,
you really like happy to have
a conversation with them.
And we like on a the perfect level.
Like you really like it,
you know,
both of us were talking about all
kinds of different crazy shad and he's,
or he's an honorable person and
he's an artist is like right away.
I was like,
I love this guy.
Know right away.
It's a perfect guy to do it.
What did you guys,
uh,
if,
if you remember,
I'm curious to see if you remember.
What did you guys talk about
while he was tattooing you?
Everything and anything,
man.
Do you remember any of the conversation?
Like is it,
we have it on it,
like a meaningful,
at the beginning.
First Sleeve?
Yeah.
At the beginning of the first leak.
A lot.
It was on video,
but then the second sleeve is like,
like about three years old.
I still have to go back.
I still,
there's a few spots on it.
It's amazing.
Most of it is a memo to Musashi peace.
Who is the guy who is the,
Oh,
and there's the graphics joker.
I thought you got rid of
the graphics Cherokee.
Yeah.
I thought you did too.
I have to suck.
It's not quite done yet.
I got it.
I think they should pump that out.
No,
it's like,
it's not really,
even before I knew what a
graphics joke or what you drew it,
right.
Stupid idea.
Yeah.
I drew it.
But I caught that shit.
That's my Jiu Jitsu.
But,
uh,
this is Jamison experience.
That Tattoo.
I did draw a lot.
I drew that in 1990.
It looks like shit now.
I like it.
Oh,
the guy who better than water,
if the guy who tattooed
for me,
it did a fucking brilliant job,
but steam was Danny
Williams and he died of a,
of cancer really?
Reselling and the bottom tattoo.
They're really crazy looking.
Samurai guy that is a meal Molto Musashi
and he's fighting a tiger and that.
So what happened?
What happened to you?
Sick artwork,
man.
So that's all my man Aaron
Dellavedova his work and he just,
he does brilliant work.
It's,
yeah,
the beach.
What was the,
what was the term for what
for you?
Like where were you,
you went from like one tattoo
and not smoking weed to like,
well,
I don't,
maybe I've heard say no
was,
um,
I,
I always like,
like tattoos.
I always liked the artwork of it.
I'm a big fan of,
I'm a big fan of music.
I'm a big fan of writing.
I'm a big fan of meat movies and cars and,
and,
and paintings and anything that you do
that expresses whatever you have inside
of yourself through some medium,
whether it's a medium of making a hot
rod or it's the medium of even designing
clothes.
Like I'm like,
like I'm wearing some
crazy tee shirt right now.
Some dude gave me,
it's a Bruce Lee who's a,
he's acting as a DJ.
I thought that was hilarious.
So,
but it's great.
It's funny,
someone's idea that's
expressed through clothes,
you know,
you can express it through furniture.
I like
my friend away in this table tables,
bad ass.
And
you can express it through anything,
but it really,
it's all the same thing.
The eye,
the idea is that everything that a person
can enjoy is someone else trying to
express some sort of positive
through whatever medium it is.
Whether it's a fucking,
well,
there's les Miserables,
50 shades of grey.
It's all the same thing.
But what was the turning point?
Do you remember the thing?
No,
I know I was probably some psychedelic
drug related to experience.
Most likely.
Yeah.
That was the the
but what got you there?
Um,
well if marijuana is a gateway drug,
I'm really unfortunately a good example.
I don't think
that it's a negative gateway.
I think we have to get over that idea.
And I think a big part of the
struggle that we have in this country,
it's a lot of conservative people
misunderstand the position of people that,
uh,
support marijuana or cannabis.
And it doesn't mean that they're mutually
exclusive and it doesn't mean that
they have to be in combat with each other.
It just means that for whatever reason,
as a society,
we have associated cannabis smokers
and users with lazy bitches.
And that's stupid.
And I think that if I have benefited as a,
an unnecessarily aggro,
you no child of the 80s if
I have benefited from the
magical gift of marijuana,
then I bet you can too.
It just needs to be used properly and
it's going to make you examine yourself in
a way that may be uncomfortable
but is most likely necessary.
You know,
and the ideas that we have connected
to any sort of psychedelic experience,
marijuana or pay,
Yo the knee,
you name it,
mushrooms automatically people
of a conservative nature.
We'll assume that the people involved
in doing this thing or being lazy or
they're being,
they're being frivolous,
they're being frivolous because they've
decided to like seek escape through
chemicals rather than
deal with the reality.
But if they really knew,
they would know that that's not the case.
If they really had experienced,
they would know that.
No,
it's exact opposite.
This,
I hate to fucking bring up this
God damn radio lab show again.
They were talking about religious
experiences and people who did acid and,
and they,
and there was uh,
there was,
uh,
they were talking about
they took these kids,
it's too in school.
Took him down to a church setting
where a church sermon was giving,
going on.
They're all religious teachers.
Okay.
All religious teachers.
I like religious students.
They all take acid and they hear a sermon,
the church,
the beautiful bells.
And they said that nine out of
10 people in the test group,
so there's 2010 have a uh,
uh,
a bullshit,
you know,
the placebo,
10 of the one,
nine,
nine of the 10 had a religious experience.
And they were saying that that
nine out of 10 also went on to,
um,
teach in the ministry,
like nine of the 10 people that took acid.
And they were talking about the concept
of whether or not you could do acid and
whether or not you could create
original religious experience.
And if you could,
why wouldn't you have that all the time?
Well,
I wouldn't ever want to look for,
well what's what we were
talking about earlier,
but like one day maybe we can get our
shitty brains to accept a state of opiate
and Mgma at the same time all the time.
I want like a low grade cocaine.
What's going on?
I mean all respect to people who are
on antidepressants and this is not an
antidepressant rant.
And I think quite honestly,
that there's quite a
few of those rants that,
or they're ignorant.
And even though,
you know,
we,
we had,
um,
a conversation with,
Kara Santa Maria who was on [inaudible],
I fucking loved her.
That girl was so fucking,
I've,
I've regurgitated some of
her facts in conversation,
not realizing I'm doing it.
I fucking was.
So I was afraid to Google her
and see what she looked like.
So I was like,
what is,
she's not hot because she
was so hot on this podcast.
Just listen to her.
You were like,
oh,
she's beautiful.
More importantly,
she's very fascinating.
Very,
very,
really fascinating.
And what was my point?
Uh,
I think psychedelics are
about three of them in a row.
Are you taking that off?
Yeah,
next week.
I'm taking her home.
He wanted to double date?
Nope.
Trying to can just hinted
rubbing his tickets
point was that she was describing
her own personal benefit from,
uh,
from using antidepressants
and her own personal,
you know,
her,
her personal benefit from like
regulating her state of consciousness,
but with the use of science.
And if you really stop and think about it,
like the,
some of the best feelings that
I've ever had have been under the,
uh,
under the influence of chemicals.
You know,
whether it's right now or whether it's,
you know,
the first time I ever did anything which
was an Mtma anything of significance
when,
when that feeling is so sensational.
Like what would life be if that
feeling existed all the time?
We automatically have this thought in
our head that that cannot be managed and
that needs to be discarded right away
immediately for the state of consciousness
that exist right now
can never be elevated.
This is what it is,
but I don't know even know that's true.
I Aye.
Aye.
I wonder sometimes because I go like,
okay,
I,
I feel like I spend my day chasing,
chasing a buzz where it's like,
like coffee in the morning and then
there's just like dead period in the
afternoon.
I'm like,
well,
before the beer cart,
when you feel it's respectable
to start drinking at five,
5:00 PM 5:00 PM
5:00 PM,
they can say,
leave me alone.
Oh God,
dad work.
Who keeps the fucking lights on.
Some of the best moments of my
life are when my wife had a job.
We were living in a,
in an apartment complex.
We had a nanny only because I was on
the road and sometimes the nanny and I
would overlap and I'd be
there when she would be there.
The best feelings my kids are,
they're sunsetting in Hollywood.
My wife fucking end up in
the door and just go and do,
they won't open a bottle of wine.
Oh motherfucker.
I remember getting like chills like
it's Christmas Eve and we crack open a
bottle of wine pouring for the nanny.
We just sit on the couch.
It's socks.
Fuck love.
I love those kind of moments.
You love leg ultimate moments
where everybody agrees.
Yes,
it's time.
Everyone's on the same page.
I think that's one of
the back open the bottle.
Everybody agrees.
It's great.
Like that's why you like sort
of the ultimate party meister.
It's like you're the guy
that would get everybody.
Ah,
fuck it.
Bert was do chef,
let's do shop,
but we do it a shot.
Give me a hug.
You fucks.
I love Ya and everybody
would get together.
I think.
Yeah,
I love that feeling.
And when,
when like it's like just
fucking someone just goes,
uh,
I go was going to be awkward if I order
a beer and some would be like if you get
one I'll get one.
I'm like,
we're fucking
right away.
Can love that feeling.
I think that's what the feeling people
get when they connect when they smoked
marijuana is that someone
likes it and then they're like,
Nah.
They're like,
oh,
okay.
It's such a great,
like there's definitely a thing that
comes with being like in that sort of
fraternity of people that know,
you know,
then no,
you'd smoked pot.
Everybody's in.
It's like,
oh we're all cool and it was right.
As much as you sort of accepts
that traditional notion of reality.
Like if you've never gotten high,
you and I have very little to talk about.
I mean we can talk about
a few things for certain.
We can talk about facts and
Statistics and history and numbers.
We can talk a lot about a lot of things,
but we can't talk about
what the fuck is going on.
When you think about someone and
then the phone rings and it's them,
you can't talk about that because
you're going to give me some scaredy cat
answer.
You're going to go well,
it was just sort of a coincidence,
no relationship whatsoever.
There's never been a statistical
correlation between you
think the mount someone
and then them calling you and not
meaning anything significant whatsoever.
It's just nonsense.
I need you to get a rip and put a tie
on where some shiny shoes with slippery
souls and walked down the
street like a gentleman.
I don't know.
But I know that when I,
a little light bulb goes off in my head
and I think about Bert Kreischer and
then I looked down at my phone and it
starts ringing immediately and it's Bert
Kreischer,
well call me crazy,
but I think something's up.
Okay.
I think there's something fucking going
on when I think about you and then all
of a sudden you call me immediately.
It happens every day nonstop,
a lot.
And you know when it happens,
you ready for this Brian Red Ban.
It happens
live in your life correctly.
When you live in your life correctly,
the universe gives you a lot
of fucking secret messages.
That's what it is.
I like yesterday,
this is something crazy.
As an example,
yesterday I was talking to my
friend who's a ginger and I'm like,
is there such things as Jewish ginger's
I've never even heard is like I've never
seen a Jewish ginger before.
She was like,
of course there is and then like two
hours later it's somebody else just is
like,
oh,
this guy,
he's a gr ginger.
He's a Jewish gender.
Have you ever seen one of them?
I'm like,
all right,
I've never talked about ginger Jewish
ginger's my whole entire life now twice in
one day
there's a possibility
that you attracted down.
There's a possibility that much like
you ever sent an email on Google,
you know it could be about anything.
You can just like send an email and say,
hey man,
I'm looking to get a life size copy
of the robot from lost in space
base and then you look in the corner
of your Gmail when you get on.
I ended up,
y'all lost in space shit.
That's reading.
Right,
right,
right.
Exactly.
So you think somebody
is reading my presently,
this is my point.
If reality is a simulation wouldn't have
followed the same principles that your
genes or your Yahoo has,
where you'll see the corners where shit,
you've sent emails about,
we'll be reoccurring themes in your
life and do that in life all the time.
I've put it out there,
but isn't it fascinating
it out there is it mirrors.
It mirrors what we know is a program.
Oh,
that's fucked up.
It's true.
You're right.
Yeah.
It's just the fucking natural course of
history of how life's going to go down.
It already happens in life.
God does it well.
The universe does.
It trickles on to you.
You sound like you're right for a cult.
I could fucking gate you just
shut up and write something.
Give me some Blue Nike Suck my Dick
and a house full of feathers I could be
called.
I've been watching this
documentary on the vice guys and made
a documentary about this fucking dude
who's a,
he's the new Jesus.
He's a Siberian Jesus.
Have you seen that Brian?
Listen,
ladies and gentlemen,
pull it up.
No,
we shouldn't pull it up because
it's a really long piece.
You guys are crazy.
I've only watched the
first two 10 minute pieces,
but it's fascinating.
There's a guy in Siberia that's created
a village and he's like the second
coming of Jesus.
He's like the new Jesus,
and he has thousands of people
that they're living up there.
Thousands.
They're all living up there.
But meanwhile,
they're living in an unbelievably,
unbelievably beautiful place.
I mean,
it is stunning.
If maybe maybe seeding
if find some photos,
but it's,
it's staggeringly beautiful.
And this guy,
he's not p appreciate anything
bad except being a Vegan.
That's silly.
But
I can't think of it.
I got to have for me Vegan fucking,
even when I was doing that clean program,
Jesus,
I'd have a chicken with
fucking lettuce wraps.
Oh,
I love spicy shit.
Yeah.
I wish that animals weren't
so fucking delicious.
It's the fucking amazing and I wish
that they didn't fucking keep making
animals.
Maybe they would just all live
forever and everyone will be a mortal.
We have enough numbers now
and just keep it going.
I had duck heartland who?
The photo of the dude.
Who's the,
the Russian Jesus.
Meanwhile,
he's got an awesome,
I don't think I ever saw Jesus smile.
He does.
What?
Green Day's plans.
Sad cause he's hurt the [inaudible] Jesus.
His pictures were like
hip hop cover albums.
I just was up
the Australian,
Jesus is a guy in
Queensland and he says he's
Jesus.
It was just in Queensland.
What's accurate level you doing?
What are you doing?
Stand up.
No,
he did a triplet and
Australia in Queensland.
Australia.
A country I've ever been to.
I'm telling you what to
say this and I don't,
I'm not shitting on America and
I'm not shitting on Kanuka Candida.
Can you guys are second.
But Australia blows everyone.
Yeah.
I love,
I love the people there.
I love their attitude.
It's like we,
we are so uptightness country,
we're,
we're really so unbelievably uptight,
especially when it comes to like
going out and having fun and relaxed.
I'd moved to Australia in a
fucking heartbeat in a heartbeat.
It's like there's this thing about America
that America was sort of founded and
created by a bunch of people that have
come here from somewhere that sucked and
they had enough and they just
made it over to some new spot.
But I think that the,
the,
the type of person that it takes to be
able to get in a boat and travel across
the ocean and land line
is finding the land.
I think it takes several
generations before
everybody fucking relaxes.
That's the bad ass motherfuckers that
could get a boat had fucking do that
because you just shook the,
the,
the loose leaf.
Scott shaking off the tree.
There were,
there was so gangster,
they gotten a goddamn
boat and traveled across.
You ever do that ends with no radio,
right?
Do you ever think about that though?
When you travel with your kids
somewhere and then you go,
how would we travel across America?
Like,
how would,
how would your family size up in a
wagon train going from New York to La?
My family would have either stayed,
I mean if you had little children,
you did stayed in Italy or Ireland,
you would have done whatever you
could do to stay where you were.
But my,
uh,
Grandfather's family came over here and
I want to say the early 19 hundreds my
grandfather's family came over from Italy
and my grandfather lived
on a farm and he said,
tell me stories about how they used
to kill rabbits with their hand,
like grandmother neck.
It's snapped them.
That was like a normal part of your life.
And there was,
you know,
winters where like they
would run out of the food.
Like there was no food.
They didn't have to go and borrow
food from people that were neighbors.
Crazy times crazy.
I know.
It's crazy.
More crazy is like,
can I say this?
I said this guessing Lee,
but like the amount of humility
your grandfather must have had,
he was a very humble guy.
You like to come here?
Oh,
you know,
I,
he got walked on by my grandmother and
my grandmother was like a really strong
woman and she used to
yell at them all right.
I was like a little kid because
my mom had me when she was 20.
And you know,
my mom did her best,
but she was really young.
You know,
when you're 20 years old and all
of sudden you're raising a baby,
that's a [inaudible] was 21
when I was born or where my,
um,
my mother was 21 rather when I was there,
I was 21 when I was born.
I might as well,
Ben and I would probably feel like,
oh my God,
this bitch is 21.
She doesn't know what
the fuck is going on.
I got to get up to
mentality immediately.
No,
they're all 40.
They could have been,
no,
no.
At the time you were born,
I don't know.
I don't know old.
They were,
I mean
me to wrap my head around now
I don't want to do the math,
but the point was my,
you know,
my mother was young and so like
growing up with like,
uh,
a young mother that doesn't necessarily
know what the fuck is going on
really makes you realize
at a young age like,
oh shit,
okay,
this isn't based,
you start looking at everything
a little differently.
He doesn't know what's going on.
I don't think she can make no,
she was okay with that,
but
both in his fucking crazy thing together,
shit.
And you know,
you realize like kind of early
the fuck.
That's crazy.
I can't imagine being,
I can't imagine that my biggest hiccup
in life was getting into standup because
by my,
I just that,
that I didn't,
I didn't have any humility at that time
of my life and my dad gave me a speech
on my 26th birthday that
was like fucking aggressive,
like really like the 20 seconds,
the 20s.
It was on my birthday.
He called me and I thought he's
going to wish me happy birthday.
And he was like,
you're a fucking loser.
Oh my.
He's like,
you make me embarrassed.
I'm embarrassing her,
my son,
I lie about you.
Oh my God,
he's,
do you know what that's
like to love private,
to have a judge said,
I heard your son,
God is life's operating by raw Oliver
stone and he's in New York turned
standard.
How's he doing?
Cause I lied in fucking court.
He goes,
that makes me sick to my stomach.
I was like,
what can I do different?
And he goes,
nothing.
I was like,
well,
can I fix this?
And he goes,
I know I failed you as a father.
And I know it.
It got me to like,
it changed my life.
Like I went,
he taught me how to get taught me how
to be humble enough to get a job in
standup because I,
you just needed to work the door.
But I thought I was above that.
I thought that I was better than that.
Like I thought that someone would just
grab me and put me on stage and I'd be
discovered.
That's how I thought it happened.
I didn't know.
You could literally be humble and say,
I want to do this.
How do I go about doing this?
Please help me test someone.
And he got me into it and
literally fucking started
doing it the next night and
six months later I had
a deal and it was like,
it was a fucking,
one of the greatest things I ever did.
I look back at that so fondly.
Those times me like I outside,
this is every single
night hanging outside.
Jim Norton,
Bobby Kelly,
Patrice O'neil,
Colin like not Colloquia.
And actually he didn't,
I didn't,
I've never actually
met him until recently.
Just throw him in there.
Cause I,
I started getting into
a tough crowd mentality.
I started living off the
credits of tough crowd.
I was like me,
Bobby Kelly.
I'm honest.
I'd never,
I'd never met Nikki there.
So No,
I mean I've seen them come,
I worked the door when
he'd come in and do the
club,
but I never knew.
You see him on stage.
It's fucking next brotherly love make
us Nick Dipaolo to me is one of the most
underrated comedians in
this kind of hands down.
No questions asked.
He's Kinda guy.
You can tell his jokes to your friend at
a bar and they fucking lose their mind.
He had a joke about her.
You remember when Katrina hit do?
It's so cruel.
It was so,
it was so fucked up.
But he goes,
yeah,
they were.
They were writing rescue,
rescue,
rescue signs on the row,
on the roof.
But I'm not doing this any Josh.
I'm so sorry Ben.
And I was like,
there's no way I'll get through it.
There was signing a rescue,
uh,
you know,
signs on the roof,
but there were misses
Belvin him instead of help,
but said Hap and once,
I'm happy to trick that fucking water
if you want some hap drink that water.
Nick Depaulo I'm not,
I'm sorry nick.
I butchered your joke.
Apologize.
I wish I knew his joke about he goes,
ah,
I'm not going to do this.
Ain't justice either.
They a lot of bills and they
haven't said the n word.
A lot of people say that rarely.
I guess you'd never put
$1,000 on a playoff game that
I know I ruined that bit,
but no,
no,
no.
Nick Depaulo was,
is one of the funniest.
I watched naughty,
naughty,
naughty and
I watched it.
Nordion rd and nick on uh,
on on the fucking same thing.
Damn.
Package shows on I want watch it cause I
respect both of those guys so much that
I go,
it's not the best shows sometimes.
Well this is what I think that show would
be fucking magic if it was uncensored
and to take nick and rd and putting on
my regular like taking Joey d as in make
him instead of talk.
Write with a Crayon.
Yeah,
it's nonsense.
It's fucking stupid.
I watched it all the time though
cause it's like I love nick and Arnie.
Someone with some fucking balls.
Please take that chair.
I'll put it on the Internet.
You'd make more money then they'll be
more people that budgeting and you could
still put it on direct TV or whatever
the fuck you're putting it on.
It's still would be,
but leave.
Let Nick Be Nick.
Let RDB already let him be crazy.
Let him,
let him talk completely unhindered
the way he,
what did I,
we were talking,
I was talking to someone recently about
bottom lines and bottom line I go to
when you,
when you're doing bad in the hecklers
attacking you and you have your comeback
and Nick Depaulo has a time,
I once again a butchering whatever this
story is because I don't remember it,
but nick said that he was getting
heckled by this girl and uh,
it was her bachelorette party and he was
on the road and some podunk town and he
was like,
he was like,
ma'am,
I hope the next time you reach
under your armpit you feel a lump.
And he goes,
I've never had an entire
crowd hate me more.
And they had to escort
him to the green room,
but he's a fucking liar.
Old School,
like old school,
kind of like,
that's the kind of dad I want
Amit dads at like my kid's school.
And I wonder if they
knew who the fuck I am.
Like then they,
then they do know who I am.
They figured out who I am,
they'll Google me and they'll go,
oh shit,
I knew you were.
This guy can be this guy around you.
Like I wonder,
I wonder if like parents,
cause he's got kids.
If they meet him and they have no clue
of who he is and then like Google him and
then they're like,
oh my God,
I can tell this joke in front of you.
He's one of the funniest
fucking human beings,
man.
I really,
very nice guy.
Do you ever do tough crowd?
Tough crowd was a
definitive show on my life.
Yeah.
I would just have my first daughter show.
I've been doing the road and I would,
and I knew a lot of those guys.
Most of those guys from doing
standard strategy that shows canceled.
It's so silly.
Bullshit.
Seems like like why would you ever,
I mean it's such an easy resource.
The,
you know,
it was easy to get comedians.
Everybody wanted to be on it.
It was very entertaining.
We'll get to talking to him
like it's pretty much a podcast.
Yeah,
it wasn't fun.
It was a limited
like time,
a time limited podcast.
This,
listen man,
we're so lucky that we are existing in
this time where you can do this thing
where you could do
whatever the fuck you want.
No one's telling us what to do.
We're doing whenever we want.
We decided to keep going.
We decided to end the podcast,
take a leak and keep going.
There's no producers is don't.
That's the beauty of a situation.
Oh,
this is when Greg Giraldo and
Denis leary hit pause for a second.
Brian,
this is a funny,
or keep it all your money story because
Geraldo never even went to the nuclear
weapons,
which is plagiarism.
He never went to that.
He never even went to that.
But Larry was so conti with them.
Like right off the bat.
Greg Giraldo was a buck
and beautiful dude.
He was just the nicest fucking guy.
He was very intelligent in a,
in a time where in my life when
no one needed to be nice to me.
There were two people that
were distinctly nice to me and,
and,
and gentle and that was
bill burr and Greg Geraldo.
Like,
you know,
Norton and,
and,
and Bobby and all those
guys were always nice to me.
But man,
good Geraldo and Bill Berg took time,
pulled me aside and like,
they were fucking great guys.
I remember one time calling
in to my buddy cowhead show,
uh,
and,
and cause Geraldo was on and calling in
to listen to Geraldo's interview cause I
just love Greg.
And I had told him and drag goes,
I'll put them on the
phone and talk to him.
And I talked to Greg for like fucking 10
minutes in between the break in a song
and just was like,
man,
how,
how's everything going?
And he was like,
well,
yeah,
he was very sincere.
Fucking fucking great guy.
He had a show,
I don't remember what network it was on,
but it was,
uh,
it was his sitcom.
It was on during when yours was right.
Yeah.
He talked about partying with
the girl that was on your show.
Which one?
Uh,
the girl with the big tits.
Who on newsradio girls are they tense?
Did Not one girl with big tits.
No.
Who was the girl and
there was beautiful girls,
but then I always
have they,
I thought her tits were so
big they had to tape them on.
Maura was the white girl with black hair.
Yeah,
she was though.
That's a really,
that's a terrible misunderstanding.
She was beautiful.
She was very beautiful
and incredibly town home.
Fucking one incredibly town
with white wine with her.
So bad.
I did a scene with her once,
I'll never forget this and I told her
and she just sort of laughed it off
because she's,
she's like really?
Like she wasn't,
she would never like
brag about her talent,
like as an actor.
And he was good,
but we did a scene together and um,
I didn't that she was acting,
I thought she was saying
something to me and I was like,
oh,
that's the words.
Oh,
well I go,
Holy Shit.
You bad ass bitch.
I go,
I didn't know you were acting.
you just fucking rocked me.
Like she rocked me with what she was
saying because the set of news radio was
very loose.
There was a lot of fucking off.
And there was also a lot of improvisation
where it's like Dave Foley was
responsible for a huge amount
of like what got on the air,
that show,
because it's sort of like,
he was like sort of like a
almost like a secret producer.
And it was because the guys who wrote
the show where like they were so open
minded and so smart and Paul Simms,
who is the executive producer was just,
it's really brilliant guy who recognized
that there was a lot of people like AMD
or like Phil Hartman or Dave Foley or
whatever who would have this in intuition
while they were on stage working out the
scenes and they would come up with new
things and to incorporate
those new things.
So Dave was like constantly tweaking
things and adding things and it was,
you know,
and being able to watch that and to
watch someone do that and to be in that
situation,
I was like,
wow.
this is,
this is like an ideal situation.
He,
uh,
I,
I was the,
is this is gonna Sound
Conti Conti but weird.
But,
uh,
so like last year was a very good year
for me and I'm also in the middle of our,
our school.
So like our kids are in third grade and,
and like now we've been at
school long enough to kind of,
and we know all the parents
and so like I was this like a,
I was the resident famous comedian parent.
Like,
oh,
he's a comedian.
I think Dave Foley's kids go to
our school now and Dave Foley,
they were like,
have you heard Dave Foley?
He spoke at a PTA.
Mom apparently is a fucking amazing dad.
Like I'm either that or it's a
guy that looks like Dave Foley.
What do you mean he's amazing dad?
Like he like shows up and
does all the shifts and,
and they were like,
no,
and I don't go into anything.
I don't even go to recitals.
Like I just fucking,
he's a very solid dude.
That was a great set.
But what I'm saying about Morris,
she did,
she was built,
oh yeah,
she's very pretty beautiful woman.
But she didn't have big knocker.
She was fucking hottest shit.
She's very,
but you have a Greg Giraldo shot across
from you guys when you guys used to
party.
Right.
And well,
we'll,
Greg was writing right
store and um,
he was,
there's a lot of guys who had TV shows.
There was a lot of guys who like
got gigs back in those days.
It's like they got a development deal
and maybe they had a few episodes.
Like my friend Tom Rhodes,
he had a show for sure.
Why can love Tom Rhodes.
He's a good dude.
He's a great dude.
And um,
I met Tom.
The first time I met him was
when we were both on NBC.
I was on news radio and he had his own
show and then he went over to Amsterdam
and he's,
Tom's beautiful,
he's fucking awesome.
But he never lost his shit,
you know,
he was,
he's always been cool.
He's always been like that.
The night I met Tom,
this is like,
in my opinion,
like a fucking ledge yet.
Comedian Tom Rhodes
is from Florida.
And,
uh,
I've told him the story a number
of times and he never really it,
but we ran into each other in Amsterdam.
We did that showtime
special with Russell Peters.
And I said,
uh,
the fucking first night I met him,
I was working in the Boston comedy club.
I came downstairs and he was at the bar
and I knew it was from Florida and I was
from Florida and I like to stand up
and I walked up to him and I was like,
I was like,
hey man,
my name's Bert.
I'm a comedian.
I just started,
I'd love to ask you.
And he stopped me,
like put his hand on my judge
has handled Manchester was like,
listen,
you started buying beers and I'll
answer every question you want.
No,
it's like,
all right.
So I started,
I put my fucking Dad's credit card down
and I fucking Bob Beers and talked to
him about comedy for like three hours.
So it was fucking great.
He was one of the one dude's,
it did,
uh,
the icehouse chronicles and we had
a long conversation afterwards.
Who was with you?
Yeah.
He was like the comradery.
So cool.
Here it's like we have like
real comedian comradery.
He was hammered and I
said I was with the two.
I think I was with the two I was with.
I had a guy with me to drive me and I,
I was like,
Tom,
let us take you to your
cause he was hammered.
Yeah.
We were trying to tell him
there's no way you're driving.
And he was like,
ah,
don't worry about me.
I sleep in a car.
I wake up and I go,
yeah,
he passed.
He slept in his car can do that.
That's illegal.
Well,
if he's sleeping in your car,
they'll arrest you.
I just had a simulation
thing happened to me.
Joe.
I uh,
that,
that Denis leary video that we
were talking about last night,
I watched this movie called happy,
which is all about depression
and stuff like that.
It's a documentary on Netflix.
I recommend.
It's all right.
But there was a guy in the movie that
was like a motivational speaker to kids
and I was like,
who is this guy?
It's the guy on the right right there.
I've never seen this guy.
Never in my life.
Yeah.
And now he's in this fucking
bitch going to be on the podcast.
Oh,
are you serious?
I saw him the second time I
ever did stand up for money.
I opened for Lenny Clarke.
I used to say it was the first time,
but it's a lie.
Ladies and gentleman.
The first time I opened up a
guy named Warren Mcdonald's.
That's the first time I ever got paid.
But the second time I ever got paid,
the truth is I opened up for Lenny
Clarke and I was in a place called js and
Pittsfield,
Massachusetts and Lenny.
Um,
he's always been like super cool to me.
He's going to look how fat Greg Looks.
Does it look grow fat
will considering like,
oh now.
Oh Brian,
where you saw that bit.
At least you know that Greg
would have been going on.
I was a horrible joke.
Yeah.
The big guy,
by the way,
Lenny has lost a shitload of weight.
Yeah.
Lenny is really good.
Wait,
wait.
Is this serious?
In that documentary he was pulling out
towels because he wouldn't stop sweating.
And I was telling,
I was talking to the girl I was
with last night and I was like,
isn't that crazy?
He's just standing there talking
to kids and he can't stop sweating.
There's like sweat all over his body.
It's documentary.
It's called happy and I just saw it last
night and never seen this guy before in
my life and I just pull up this
video and he's in this video.
It's so fucking,
where's the part where Greg,
we did that.
A movie together.
Here comes the boom,
the Kevin movie and Lenny Clarke was in
that movie because it was shot in Boston
and Lenny played a local Boston guy,
Lenny Clarke,
which I fucking love that guy,
but he's lost a lot of weight man.
He lost a ton of where he looks great.
I mean he's like really lean.
He doesn't have a,
I've got it.
All right,
Dalia guy gotta work right
for reasonable price.
And I could come back,
we get out of a piece
and like they did an,
is this where they might find out?
Well,
it's,
it's about the time,
I think right here.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
what happened to lap Denis leary?
He gets mad at Greg.
Geraldo has prepared material.
It's really hilarious.
And that's how he found out
where they were buried the ball.
Yeah,
I know.
Is it during the news of hazard?
I Dunno.
Someone should like find this off air
and figure it out because it's a really
good job.
Well,
there might be their outcome for a,
what is a nonviolent way to,
to solve the problem with the copy that
we hate that hate dozens got weapons
pointed this.
I don't think so.
No,
you're right.
Like Russia for example,
that big Russian war.
Yeah.
There are things that,
there are things that are,
yeah.
But there our approach to their economic
benefit that we're giving them in order
to,
for them to stop developing their weapons.
I mean,
I heard weekly they agree to stop,
uh,
stop building nuke.
If American women agree to get their
nails done at least twice a week.
I ran a good boy.
You're,
you can make so many
jokes before the show.
It's not even applying.
Unbelievable.
He's got to,
he's got pocket follow.
Not Good.
I'm just saying.
I don't know.
I'll have,
it was my dad.
That's kind of what we do here.
A comedy writer.
Oh boy.
The guy who did all the homework and
then after there was any more that needed
to be done.
That's a good point.
And if you would try it,
a little comedy writing,
maybe your show and still be on the air.
Can you tell me all the time
he just crushed it,
you know?
But that's
[inaudible] happens when dudes get famous.
I think you guy can't
come along and clown.
You
tell me about it.
It's a first time I went on the road and
I realize there are killers that I've
never heard of.
No.
When a guy gets famous to
a point where you're uh,
uh,
Tom Cruise or any,
any,
any sort of a person who's been in moving.
Yeah,
Dennis Leary,
when that came out and had
been in a ton of movies,
he had been in some really
high profile movies.
I mean he thought of himself
as a guy who had made it,
so I think he probably assumed he was
going to get a certain level of respect.
So where all,
maybe if you did a little writing,
your show would still be on the air.
That was like a nuclear weapon
that he didn't see common.
He didn't see that.
Tell
me that all you got detonated is that,
oh for that was Hubris.
You look at the look on journalists face
and you can see his eyes twitching and
you can see him go angry going three,
two,
I got this,
I got this.
And then like making is making
it as tactical colonists had.
You could see that happening almost.
It's a superior mind,
superior mind.
Just not as famous but a superior product.
Like what he would,
he would put out his points of view.
It'd be superior.
I'll watch his hour.
I got the idea that there would be
like something funny and sign it.
Someone prepared,
like look at him.
He for being a bully.
But that's the idea.
That was ridiculous.
Like it's so crazy.
Like,
oh look at the painter.
He went and painted
like,
what the fuck?
It's a,
there's a,
there's a certain personality that,
and I'm not going to speak,
I don't,
I'm not saying this is Denis leary,
but there is certain personality that's
so arrogant in that the way I say it
will be so much better
than the way you say it,
as opposed to what I say is
better than what you say.
So like,
like you could hear the statement
before him when he says,
oh,
well we're going to go to
war with a country like the,
it was very arrogant and he was like,
yeah,
like that great Russian
war that does fucking work.
You're not listen to the words you're,
you're,
you're overlooking the thought.
Well,
he hasn't this idea that
somehow or another he's going
to be able to solve what
hundreds of scholars and heads of states
and diplomats and emissary workers and
no one can solve.
No one can solve.
But he's going to come along and tell
you exactly how things need to be blunt.
The ideas of,
first of all,
the communication between nations where
they don't even speak the same fucking
language.
Yeah.
And how difficult that shit is.
It's so fucking hard just to understand
things and cultural context and explain
those different people that are in
your country that you're sort of
representing.
Because Koreans are not like Americans
and Americans and all I Koreans,
people that live in North Korea do not
understand how we're living in North
America and the people in North
America for the most part,
really a fairly ignorant about what
the fuck is going on in North Korea.
And one of the big reasons is because
we can't fuck them communicate with each
other because we could
communicate with each other.
If everybody in Korean and North Korea
knew how to speak English and they all
could read the shit on the Internet about
how the world is run and what the fuck
is really going on in the country and
how the rest of the world views things,
they would probably slowly
but surely take action.
But the fact that there they're
separate from the rest of the world,
in fact they speak this one,
you know,
very unique sort of a language.
It's difficult to learn and he's in
translatable very easily to English or
Spanish or
there's Korean.
Not translatable is difficult
symbol.
You know the,
the,
this,
the way things are written,
we're good friends are Korean
and that when you go to a car,
we went to a Korean barbecue.
It was Roy Choi.
He's the guy that started the Taco truck.
The concept of the TACO truck.
It's him.
He started,
it started.
It was the first guy,
the premise of these correlation,
these gourmet taco trucks.
He's Asian.
Yeah.
Roy Choi.
He does.
He's good friends with Bordain
Asians don't give a fuck dude.
Then you get things done.
They get things done.
I don't think they really get it done.
If I can get things done,
they really do the
fucking future of America.
When you eat,
how the fuck did they ever
figure out how to get,
I don't even know what you've said yet.
Full.
A full like strangle hold
on the manufacturer of like
electronic parts and TV's
and
cars.
Cars,
cars are over there now.
They're going to wear in Detroit.
No one's doing cars in Detroit.
Well,
isn't Chrysler stolen to
Detroit and hasn't forward?
No,
but no one's in Detroit.
Detroit's apparently imperil because
everyone took their business to Asia.
Why?
It's,
it's more,
is it more,
is it more a,
an idiocracy not idiocracy a theocracy,
not theocracy.
What's worth looking for?
Any is a accuracy.
What do you,
what are you trying to where like where
it's like the idea of the state is
better than the person.
So everyone looks up to the state and
it's something like that where they care
about their job.
Like Americans just don't care.
Well,
you know what happened is first of all
the cars they made sucked that that
happened in American.
Yeah.
This something happened.
We have to,
there was a period where
we got really lazy.
What the fuck went wrong from like 1973
the Ford Tempo and 90 fucking Ford tempo
is a fucking was a,
that was a phone in job by the Americans.
Like that car sat dick Suck
Dick in 1989 Ford tempo
for Tiempo.
What the fuck happened to the Mustang?
Okay.
Because I can say this,
I can say this,
I have a Mustang today.
I have a Shelby gt 500
and I fucking love it.
Okay.
But that's a 2010 and between like
1965 and 1972 or 73 they had some dope
fucking car.
Really like to 69 but then something
happened and like the 70s and the 80s like
you call that up fucking Mustang.
What are you a communist?
What did would a terrorist infiltrate
the fucking the four plants and hold down
the designers by gunpoint
and gay up all the drawings.
I go,
oh fuck.
Do you call that by the way I spelled gay.
G H e y them gave them Joe homosexuals
like,
cause I wonder if it was a,
it had to do with homosexuality and the,
and the fear of homophobia.
And they took all these great gay
designers that were super closeted in the
fifties and then got,
and then there was this
manliness and they disappeared.
You trying to say that Dick
Suck and design the corvette?
No,
there's no way you can tell me as a man,
what is sexy without
knowing sexy as a man.
What the fuck are you
talking about Pete Townsend?
Corvette is the sexiest
car you can put me in.
Is it really?
I just drove one from Miami to Marco
Island and I tell you right now,
the second I sat in that seat,
I would let the steering wheel be close
to my face cause I wanted it there.
It was just fucking,
it was God,
God kind of car.
Was it a corvette?
Which here?
Brand new,
brand new 3000 miles convertible.
There's new ones.
Was it a four 26 I have no,
I have no idea what 26 is.
They have the zero six zero six
engine and suspension and okay.
Convertible.
So fucking hot.
Like I just melt Cooley Shit.
Now
that's not a corvette,
Brian.
That's a god Damn Miata and it's pink.
How dare you?
How dare you hate America on
this podcast hating or my rook.
Cool.
I got to pimp.
Well,
why don't you go poop man.
We'll wait.
We'll hold on.
Yeah.
What time is your ra common show tonight,
Brian.
And can kind of,
can we guide people in
your general direction?
I'm just going to try
to get up somewhere now.
When you do that,
what do you do?
You just show up and say,
oh I didn't try to sneak my way in.
Hey,
my name's Brian Red Band and
you might know me on Twitter.
Is that what you do?
Why don't you start it
started start a a room.
Your own Brian.
Huh?
I did.
I have like three rooms every.
So do you think ever will
be all contained under one roof?
Do you think that ever the full desk
squad family will have podcast studios in
one gigantic warehouse and
cause that's what I'm saying.
I'm at the saying we also duplicate
this at the Onnit compound in Texas.
Why didn't,
why not?
Yes.
Austin fence.
Thousands of acres are on
lake plus deer to shoot.
How do we get it?
How do we get a power bitch?
Did I say what?
What?
Maybe we can have her
own fucking satellite.
Okay.
How do we get it?
Oh,
like a death squad,
like studio in a warehouse
where we can make TV shows.
I don't want to make it a CV,
so why not?
Why not?
It just needs to be an umbrella.
If I'm making a TV show,
here's my next TV show.
I'm going to play it
cool.
Around the spine.
Is Boring,
boring for you bitch?
It's not 99% of the people
he is.
We were very close to a sign.
I can't say with WHO.
There's a,
there's a show that is a,
um,
uh,
a lot of it is based in the podcast.
What are you doing?
Taking text messages?
Come at them live on the air.
No,
this person said that they
got a new phone number.
They're like,
sorry,
I got a new phone number and
I thought they were lying,
but now they're sending
me pictures of this.
Is that,
is that,
who is that?
It's an Aussie.
Is that Kadafi?
Yeah.
All right,
so might be not the
person I'm thinking of it.
Okay.
You getting someone sending you a murder?
The people.
What's that?
What's a new TV show you're doing?
Oh,
it's uh,
it's based a lot of it on his like
controversial subjects and a lot of it,
it'll be all of it.
We'll start off from the podcast,
like examining all
sorts of different ways.
There's no tenant,
well,
we sort of have a tentative title,
but I'm not necessarily happy with it.
So the idea is like the way we've done
the podcast where we explore all these
different ideas,
whether it's a shamanism or,
or big foot or Ufo
shows are fringe topics,
crop circles,
reincarnation,
psychics,
and we're going to talk
about it on the podcast.
I'll have a guy like you or Ari or Duncan
or Jolie or any comedian come on and
we'll say,
you know what?
It's like,
we'll do it right now.
What do you think about big foot?
Do you think?
Do you think that is possible?
There could be an undiscovered primate
that people have been talking about
reporting for ages and
it's somehow or another,
it alluded photography except for a
few really questionable photos and some
really fucking shitty video
that looks fake as fuck.
Put all that aside,
Paul,
the hoaxes aside,
do you think it's possible?
It's possible.
100%.
Why do you think?
Cause I believe,
whoa.
Yeah.
I believe,
wow.
I believe in Loch lochness monster.
I believe in Tuba.
Coffee can fly.
Do I believe I can fly
pee on you if you're a 14 year old girl
and you didn't know why you were there?
I definitely believe that I have
the capability to fly in my body.
I just haven't figured it out.
And we'll,
once we do tap into that,
I will be able to fly.
Okay.
But like Bill Hicks,
she used to say star on the ground floor,
like set a great joke
about the young man acid.
Thought he could fly lept to his death.
What a tragedy it goes when an idiot
because you taught him can fly.
Why did he start off from the ground go?
You feel like that?
I remember when Star Wars Wars,
Star wars return of the Jedi came out.
No,
no,
no.
Uh,
empire strikes back came out.
I remember watching Luke move stuff with
his mind and I remember being in the
back of my car trying
to do that hardest fuck,
like staring at objects,
trying to make shit swear to God.
I was like,
that seems logical.
Well there's certain aspects of
life it seems so preposterous.
Unrelenting electricity.
What the fuck is that?
It just hits you.
Have you seen those Tesla and
like experiments where he was like
touching electricity and it was like a
Bolton's flying big Tesla coil
and is connected to his arm.
Hold on.
Have you seen any of those photos?
Did Tesla just can I,
have you seen the new Tesla fucking car?
Did you see them all explode when
hurricane sandy hit the beach in a,
in,
in New Jersey?
What?
Yeah,
there was a whole warehouse
that had like this.
Uh,
they were,
uh,
they had a dock in,
they had all these new
Karmas.
That's what it was.
The Fisker Karma.
Was it a Tesla as though
the grant?
It's,
it looks gorgeous.
Quite a few.
Yeah.
Really beautiful electric cars right now.
But the Fisker Karma is the one and they
have like a 16 of them I think exploded
on the,
on the docks.
They had them on the docks and
the water came up on the water,
hit these fucking electric
transformer clocking blew
up and everybody was like,
Oh okay.
Shit.
I don't think they knew that would happen.
What happens if you drive?
We're fucking standing water.
What have you tried to home from a flood?
Is Your fucking car explode?
Okay.
Cause I can deal with my car shorting out.
It's sitting,
they're scared to leave.
If I can save like two bucks a gallon,
but my car explodes when I hit a puddle.
Is that going to happen?
Is that what the fuck is really going on?
That does that Tessa looks bad.
Shit,
we've won a,
it was either murdered,
murdered motor trend
or road and track car.
The year one of those big
magazines made it the car,
the or the uh,
Tesla,
not the roadster but the larger car.
Something that something asks.
It's a like a four door and uh,
apparently it's just a
marvel of engineering,
but
the real problem is going to
be a row state taxes on roads.
The roads are going to shit.
This is a lot
problems though.
Then another problem is the fact that
everybody wants to pretend that buying
some sort of an electric car removes
you from the fossil fuel food chain.
Yeah.
But it doesn't and in fact it connects
you with some even shady or minerals on
like a really large scale like lithium
ion and all those different minerals.
A lot of those or conflict minerals,
they come from the Congo,
they come from Afghanistan.
They come from like if I was Brian Count,
I'd say I've got a stone.
If I was a amber Lyon,
I'd say,
uh,
what was it?
She was fine.
Bahrain please.
Not In the bottom lane lane.
Yeah.
The,
you know these,
these minerals that you,
you need to create a lithium
ion battery by the way.
Mad Labs,
Brian Callan and mad love to amber line,
which is fucking with you.
Those minerals that you
need to make batteries.
They come from like really fucking
imprisoned and poverished areas,
their conflict minerals,
lithium ion is officially
like a conflict mineral.
Like a lot of the shit that you
need to even make cell phones.
It's like,
I think vice had a guide they had,
they did a a vice guide to travel episode
where Shane Smith went to the Congo.
I don't know why they're
not all the travel channel.
I would love to see one of their
fucking shows because it's too deep.
They go to the same shipboard aim does.
No,
they go way further than Baroda and
further extended mean close assignment
clothes where vice vice goes to the
fucking Congo deep,
deep,
deep and talks to warlords.
Really?
Did they go looking for dinosaur?
Yeah,
I would.
I'd love to see that.
I didn't they you put that on,
why not?
We enjoy watching her on the Internet.
Why can't travel,
boy
your correct.
However,
most people that run these organizations,
whether it's a network or you know,
you know cable or,
or whether it was broadcast television,
they,
they're very conservative because
they're trying to sell advertising.
Yeah.
So when a,
when a company like vice comes along
and they have like really in there,
they have no respect for any corporation
at all because they'll do what the fuck
they need to do to make what they think.
They have videos where Hamilton Morris
goes into the jungle and he's taking
Chris Drugs and align on
his back and you know,
I mean it's like they're not going
to sell tide during those times.
You know,
they're going to have to accept
that they're not yourself time,
but they do see that's
what's really stupid.
It's like there's weird sort
of game that we play.
Whereas we pretend that the people that
see all the fucked up things that you
can find on the Internet are not the
same people that wash their clothes.
Yeah.
That wash their clothes
or wash my clothes,
my gas or any of the variables and the
end of the things where we try to target
people.
We're all,
we're all the same fucking people,
man.
And yet we just have
access to different shit.
Now we need to accept that.
You need to just stop pretending that
we're living in some sort of a Catholic
school,
you know,
a Sandra Bullock movie view of the world.
It's not,
it's not reality.
Reality is there's a lot of fucked up
shit about out there and I can find it
now.
I can find it on the Internet.
It's really easy.
So you need to sort of adjust your
expectations accordingly because there's a
lot of evidence,
a lot of evidence that shows that reality.
It's pretty fucking slippery.
Yeah.
There's a lot of nutty shit outfit,
but that tells the car
looks bad is fuck yeah,
but it will explode if he hit a puddle.
What a horrible feeling.
It look dope.
I like the,
uh,
that's the four 26.
That one that Brian just put up as the,
uh,
the new corvette convertible.
That's,
it's got a 505 horsepower.
The last version of this,
uh,
this engine,
I think it's called the ls one,
but it's a,
might be wrong,
but it's a huge fucking power and
torque that's also in the Zr one,
the same engine.
They supercharge it and the Zr one,
it produces 648 horsepower.
This is like for people who like
talk about like muscle cars.
This is like the greatest era of a
muscle cars in the history of the fucking
world,
Nolan.
Yeah.
The muscle cars that people are creating
now actually can take turns and they
actually have good brakes.
Like this is a Shelby
Mustang they have now.
That's unbelievable.
The regular button,
they have the three Oh two boss Mustang.
That's like,
you know,
it's like,
they're like moderately powered.
It has 440 fucking horsepower.
It's unbelievably powerful.
Is it the Dodge Dodge
Challenger challenger?
Yeah.
We went to muscle car though.
Then we went to drive um,
uh,
Lamborghini's and Ferrari's and Porsche's
on a track for a triplet and the
dude's just wanted to
drive the dodge challenger.
They would take you out for
a ride and they were like,
this is more fun for us to drive.
Why is that?
I have no fucking idea.
But they did everything and they do the,
the,
the burnouts where they spin in circles.
Like it's just more fun.
Like the,
those things.
I,
you know,
I think like,
I definitely have driven a ton of those,
uh,
Lamborghini type cars.
Those things are fun as fuck,
but it is a different drive
than like it is really,
you don't feel as loose maybe as you
do as a dodge challenger and dodge
challenger.
You're fucking sliding and you're,
it's fun feeling it.
Yeah.
Well they have a,
they
have a broad sort of a um,
uh,
you could pick from like a
lower horsepower engine to
like a really ridiculous
engine and those things.
Yeah,
you could like ramp
it up and there's a lot of people take
those cars and they ramp them up even
more.
Like the Hennessy Hennessy makes a 700
horsepower when those I love and that you
get like those special edition cars.
Yeah.
Well what they are though,
like the muscle cars of old,
those things,
you couldn't take corners
in them like this.
These are completely different animals,
but the challenger is
still like a muscle car.
Whereas like the Camaro has become almost
like a sports car because they handle
so well.
Might've been,
it might've been a Camaro they were
driving now that I'm thinking about it,
but like we were taking
corners in the lamb,
Lamborghini and like 90 miles an hour.
Yeah.
Taking corners fucking insane.
You can do ridiculous
shit with sports cars.
I drove,
I flew to Italy for a day to
drive a Ferrari down the coast.
Like I had to fly,
I had to drive a flight.
I think I texted you about it.
Yeah.
Which one did you drive?
Uh,
I have no fucking clue,
but it was,
I just drove down the coast and I had a
chase car in front of me and test score
by me.
They just taped it and I just fucking Lou,
why was so much fun?
Like those paddles up,
up,
up.
Just for lying.
Yeah.
Those paddle shifters.
A lot of people are upset
about that shit though.
A lot of people think
that a real sports guy,
you should shift it manually and that
just because it's quicker to shift it with
the paddles,
like you're missing out
on part of the experience.
And I kind of agree,
man,
because I like shifting my own gears.
I just do fun about it.
I did too,
but there's so many people that probably
have never learned how to do that.
They can't learn on a Ferrari,
and I'm sure that's just a sales thing
because the paddle shifters are much
easier.
Yeah,
way,
ways,
but it's not as satisfying.
It's not,
it's not that it's hard to shift.
You're on gears,
but there's something that's like
mechanically engaging about the clutch in
sliding and shifter for
letting the clutch out,
hitting the gas the same time.
So it was something super sexy when
you met a girl that knew how to drive a
stick and you were like,
yeah,
like,
you got to,
you're a good dad.
Especially if it was like a
fucking Mustang or something crazy.
This dirty pitches out
there driving a big fat VA,
blah,
blah.
She wants to drive.
When you go to the movies
and you've got to say no,
and you've got to not let it be on
top of the first time we fuck either.
It's very important and then
establish dominance immediately.
Bert Kreischer that I grabbed that bitch
and let her know the feeling of gravity
and the density of the
bones and your hips.
You know what I'm saying?
Brian?
Hollaback.
Ooh.
So bird crusher.
How much time do you spend on the road?
Lately?
I'm fucking Dick load.
I'm on the road every week.
I feel like I'm home two days this week.
I'm going to take a leak.
Talked to Brian about it.
Okay.
This is in the podcast.
It's been four hours.
Just five minutes.
Brian,
I'll tell you a story.
All right.
Tell me a story.
City.
Okay.
Um,
do you wanna hear the story
that I had going to make it?
Oh,
okay.
I'll tell you a good story.
It's story.
This is the reason no listened
to the Brian Bird podcast
because I find you funny too often.
Oh,
thank you.
I find you funny all the time.
No,
no.
But we like,
like I listened to the podcast and when
I hear you say things that fucking fit
maybe stopped Joe or like dice,
like you said,
like two or three things that made me
laugh so hard during the dice podcast.
I'm smoking in the studio right now,
like a bad boy.
What's in that room right there?
That's a behind me is just an empty room.
There's a lot of empty
rooms here at the studio,
so I'll tell you this story.
Okay,
Brian.
All right.
Um,
so I checked into,
I did Columbus and then I did
right after that I did at Kentucky,
right?
Chucked into the Kentucky Hotel.
Uh,
the hotel in Kentucky
and I have four bags.
I shirts,
I've shirts for two weeks.
So I four bags a bellman takes my bags,
take some,
I have to take it,
let them take it in my room.
You know,
he's going to get a tip.
We go in the elevator.
He asked what I do.
I said,
I'm a comic.
We get out and second our door opens,
another door opens and it's a,
it's a older white dude.
And he walks out like three steps behind
us and he follows me down the hallway,
three steps behind us,
all the way,
all the way until we get
to the end of the row,
the hall where my door is.
And I'm like,
is he going to my room?
Turns out he's in the room
directly next to mine,
so as he goes to open the door and like,
like put his key in.
I jokingly in front of
this bellman thinking,
he laugh.
I go,
hey man,
if you want,
we can open up that center
door and hang out all weekend.
And the guy now I like nervous and not,
and he's trying to get
his key in and he's like,
no,
I don't.
I don't want to do that.
And I go,
well,
it could be cool with
like get to know them.
I said this to this guy,
say that,
take it fucking around.
I'm going to kiss you or so just
fucking around or even bring that up.
We'll just fucking around.
Just fucking round as a comic.
Should do.
All right,
but what if he says yes?
I don't think he will.
He's an older man,
but what if he did?
He's an older man.
I'll tell you.
Let me tell you.
Let me,
I'll tell you the story.
That's why get I checked into the
Kentucky and I got to do the Kentucky
and or whatever to Louisville,
and I have four bags with me and the
bellman takes my bags up the elevator for
me and I got them on.
Is this a gay store?
No,
it's not at all.
It's really,
it's one of the funnier things I've done
in a little bit of music to the back of
it.
Yeah.
This is,
this is a strong enough story
to close the podcast that way.
It might be,
might be roadkill,
ghosts,
choir,
beggars guild,
and we're going to play
that in the background.
Come on,
sweetie.
Let me design this thing.
I know what I'm doing.
Trust me.
Oh,
did you pull up miss B?
You can't kiss me.
You got to stop that.
You know,
we're playing that out.
We already did that
today with a Brad Pitt,
Stephen Dorff,
the roadkill ghost choir,
and the song is
beggars guild.
We need to get a desk,
quad iTunes account.
Don't worry when you
just order things online,
you know we need real internet.
Hi.
Real Internet death squad one.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll do.
We can do one this week,
Sarah.
We want to do Fridays there.
We could do Fridays.
There was a column because
I had the ice house.
Okay,
beautiful.
All right,
here.
Is that no,
Bert Kreischer.
What were you trying to tell me?
Who are you telling me,
buddy?
What were you telling me?
Columbus,
Ohio.
Fuck Nick.
Nick.
I just invented it so I
never heard it myself.
Probably the wrong song for this button.
It's the perfect song fest.
So tell me what happened.
A little,
a little fine.
Plus we had a little more volume.
So I check into the Kentucky Improv
and a black dude texted my bags.
He grabs her bags,
puts him on the trail trailer thing.
It brings him to the elevator.
I gotta let them take it in the room.
He's earned his tip,
right?
Right,
right.
So we take them up to my room.
He says,
what are you doing something?
A comedian?
He goes,
okay,
and we don't talk.
After that door's open.
Second word,
elevator doors open the doors next to us
in the elevator next to us to open and
an older white dude
walks out and follows us.
Any ghosts us down like the whole hallway.
Everywhere we go,
he follows us.
He's going wherever
the fuck we're growing,
but get all the way down
to the end of the hallway.
How far away is he walking behind you?
Three feet behind us the whole time.
That mother fucker unconscious.
It's awkward.
It's awkward and we're both know.
Didn't confront him all noticing it.
So we get to the last
door and I'm thinking,
is this guy going to my room?
I would assume that guys
try and do something bad.
You did something really wrong going on,
but I would think though,
why would you do what we do it?
What?
The last thing you would do,
Joe?
Listen,
here's what happens.
First of all,
when someone is mirroring
you like that three,
there'd being very disrespectful
because they're not.
They're not just the,
not just following you.
They're letting you know they're following
you and they're doing it in a very
arrogant way or they're being flirty?
Well,
they could be.
There's what happened?
Could be psychotics.
Here's what happened or what would you do?
Meet up immediately.
I would ask them what
the fuck is going on?
Watch what he does.
It turns out he's in the room next to me.
So he was going to his room.
So as he goes I was drunk.
See you're paranoid.
Nobody was thinking about it.
Who is scared about life?
I have a lot,
a lot.
I was thinking about more black.
I knew I was a comic and I wanted him to
nudes know that I knew Kevin Hart cause
that's what I thought he was going to.
No,
no.
Hold on.
And so the guy,
the guy,
old guy goes to open his door and
I jokingly now told the Black Guy,
I'm a comic but I haven't
done anything funny.
So I jokingly look at the old
guy and I go pay if you want,
we can open up that connecting
door and we can hang out.
Always.
It gets better.
It gets better by to the
guys now can't get his,
cause he's now had panicked him
and he can't get this door open.
And he goes,
no,
I don't want that happened.
And I go,
no,
it'd be cool man.
We'll open it up or hang out with like
the darkness and just talk to each other
at night and he can't get his door
open and finding is this door open?
And he goes,
I don't want that to happen.
The door opens before you can close it.
I stick my head in and I go,
hey man,
if you change your mind,
knock and scratch.
So he goes,
no.
And he shuts the door and he's
fucking panicked.
And I looked to the black guy,
the black guy's gone,
he's in my room.
Okay.
So I go,
fuck.
I did that joke for nothing.
So I go into the room and the
was putting the bags down and uh,
he gets done all the
bags and I go to take,
you might want to get
ready to cue the music.
Brian,
he,
I go to give him a tip and the black guy
looks at me and shakes his head and he
goes,
no.
I said,
well,
I've got to give you a tip,
man.
Took my bags up here and there's
no just knocking scratch.
So I look at the black,
I go,
okay.
So I knock and I scratch to the room goes,
he's on the ground.
Like so the guy in an extra
room called downstairs?
No,
no,
no.
The Black Guy,
the guy who I told the joke
for in the first place,
I heard the whole thing and he goes,
no man,
don't do it.
You got to knock and scratch.
So I knocked his scratched
and the fucking guys like,
I don't want to hang out,
man.
Bird crashed.
That's rude.
Oh,
it was fucking the funniest guy in a
bar or die with a lot of insecurity and
you're fucking with his head.
Funniest thing I've ever done.
The bed's Kinda bullyish.
You feel bad for that
poor dude ass so bad.
The whole
weekend.
I kept talking loud as fuck in my room.
Just going.
I know he's listening to me.
Why don't you just knock
on the door and say,
hey man,
I'm a comedian.
I'm really sorry it was passed.
It was passed.
That is past that.
Oh,
so you had to just like fucking just
burn all the evidence.
You just had a fucking shoot
rockets from helicopters.
Is this incredible hulk music is the end.
This is the,
I could fuck it.
I could do the gets
friend.
Well thank you very much Debra.
Crisis One Ohio.
You Sir are a bad motherfucker.
Has such a great time today.
Ma'Am.
You're welcome.
Anytime my friend,
if there's anything we could
do to help you in any way,
shape
forum,
you've done everything you could
imagine my vodka company when it starts,
well not us know Bert Kreischer.
We will launch that bitch
machine vodka in motion.
Lazy Gentlemen Machine Vodka
just became an official sponsor
of the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
They have one year free sponsorship.
We will talk about machine vodka for one
year is absolutely zero money and you
will buy it all up and Bert Kreischer.
We'll have a helicopter and a
place on a volcano in Hawaii so
I can fly to our Texas compound with our
high wall kind of by Terence Mckenna's
house on the big island and converted
into a Bikini factory where the hottest
girls in the world will make $1,000 an
hour and they'll make bikinis and leaving
Easter will be one of my models.
Exactly.
With Rachael Ray,
les Miserables.
Bulls will play in the background
until everyone becomes a sex slave.
Zombie robot control afternoon to talking.
Yeah,
it was beautiful.
This is what we
should do all the time,
but do this once a week.
You were the reason I have a podcast,
I am grateful.
Fucking days in the podcast is successful,
but Brian,
you know how I know how
to get a cup pod cast up.
We are all together in
this crazy soup of life.
Bert Kreischer.
Yeah,
I am as happy for you as you are for me.
We are both together.
Very fortunate along with Jamie,
the new guy along with Brian.
You said anything Jamie,
shut up and it's not ready yet.
It's not ready to go
through an apprenticeship.
You need to see success and failure.
Just
like puzzles.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is the end of the commercial free
podcast here at the Joe Rogan experience.
What can you do to give thanks,
wait,
can you do incorporate all the
messages of the Bert Kreischer,
Bert,
Bert podcasts into your life,
bitches,
bird cast,
baby.
Check it out.
The Burt cast at Bert Bert,
bert.com you can find all the information.
Incorporate those lessons to Dli.
Hey,
don't be a con.
Be looking in the mirror.
See,
get Josh Gad up,
pictures and shit together.
We love you,
but first you must love yourself
in order for you to love yourself.
You must respect herself in order
for you to respect yourself.
You need to get your shit together,
bitch.
Give yourself advice for 10 you are an
outside and objective observer of your
own existence.
And what kind of advice would you give
yourself to get your shit together and
why won't you follow that Shit Yourself?
Stop pretending you can't
bullshit a bullshitter.
Socket that squad 2013 bitches.
Where here,
fuck up my Mayan raise Odin son.
Praise Odin bitches.
Oh,
Adam knows what the fuck is up.
We'd go to rubbing.ting.com and
save 50 bucks and goblets Jihad.